can a raw egg cure a hangover we've
created a facility to test the world's
greatest hangover cures and we're
testing them all I'm dr. Keller wertham
doctor of internal medicine I'm Fran
Kranz I'm not a doctor but I've been
hung over a lot
welcome to the GQ hangover that
Christian Christian age how late were
you up probably I don't know 4:35 let's
maybe we can retrace the night through
images okay here we are we're at a bar
right and I was out at the Santa Anita
racetrack was this in the daytime that
was what are we drinking whiskey bourbon
I can't see what you're drinking in that
picture but again you're a nice company
I'm just drinking it all in well what's
what's the hangover feeling like it's a
little bit like right here a little bit
right here if you drank for a long
period of time so the drinks that you
had earlier in the day have already
broken down into some of the metabolic
products that cause a hangover we did
the breathalyzer you blew a point one
three which means in addition to being
hungover you're still quite intoxicated
and then we brought you to friends
special motor skills tested oh yeah my
favorite contraption you have to flick
the ball into the wooden cup hole given
where you are from a blood-alcohol level
I was impressed that you got even - I
think we have a special cure for you
today especially as a chef you might
appreciate the organic crudeness of it
yeah absolutely you want to you want to
get to it definitely okay sweet right
Olli Christian knows how to drink uh he
probably does a lot he's in the food
industry that's common so him at a point
one three he's actually a lot less drunk
than you or I would be certainly or
certainly me I don't I don't know nobody
he's got a little bit of headache he's a
little fuzzy but he wants to you know
kind of shoot the [ __ ] more than sort of
focus on any of the tasks at hand so
we've got an interesting cure for him
today yeah we've got the the Prairie
oyster Prairie oyster this was new to me
really excited about this one this is
this isn't this is an old one that's the
raw egg
Tabasco Worchester salt and pepper
this is a real old hangover cure there's
a protein in egg called cysteine that
helps speed up the metabolism of one of
the byproducts of alcohol so it speeds
up the nasty chemical called
acetaldehyde that gives us a hangover so
you can excrete it faster but it doesn't
speed up the metabolism of actual
ethanol or the alcohols my hypothesis
with these Prairie oysters is it's gonna
you know marginally speed up his ability
to get rid of the hangover inducing
chemicals but it's not really going to
help him clear the alcohol any faster
some Prairie oysters what exactly is a
very high stir a cure is old as the 15th
century just tell me when to go [ __ ] Wow
take your time oh okay
well present its really aggressive okay
Wow feeling better already you've never
eaten six frogs before to be honest I
don't really eat raw eggs ever it's like
a thing I have let's see if it works
your blood pressure dropped 160 over 90
104 for the pulse your heart rates still
up I imagine you're still a little bit
dehydrated 1 1 3 but that's where your
body lives point so I think we need to
check friends favorite game we need to
go flick some balls you got one minute
to put that ball in that Cup as many
times as you can
ready go great start - hey sorry amazing
Oh
6
I mean I'm impressed 6 6 AG 6 flicked
balls should we go sit down and talk
about this yeah let's marvel at it let's
go oh yeah egg champion in the ball
flicking champion here's the deal
acetaldehyde is a nasty breakdown
product of ethanol that's 30 times more
toxic than ethanol and it accumulates in
your body and makes you feel like okay
it needs to be further metabolized on to
water and carbon dioxide but to do that
it needs this thing called glutathione
it eats up all this glutathione and the
only way to make more glutathione is to
eat sisty insisting is in the egg now
there are some other things in a prairie
oyster besides just the egg you know the
salt is going to replace your
electrolytes the Tabasco has capsaicin
which is actually an analgesic or a pain
reliever and you get a little bit of or
sister which is to make your body less
acidic okay so there's your lecture on
alcohol metabolism for the day I'm
hoping that didn't make your headache
worse actually like way better to be
honest this is kind of gone Christian we
definitely learned a lot I'm gonna grade
the Prairie oyster at I'm going to give
it a B maybe a B - and and this is why
cysteine the the protein the amino acid
there in the eggs has been shown to
increase your metabolism of these nasty
products that cause a hangover but you
don't have to eat a rug to get it in
fact you get more cysteine in a cooked
egg so don't worry about grossing
yourself
out or risk in getting Salmonella eat a
hard-boiled egg really or lots of them
and and you'll be better off I'm gonna
go I'm gonna go a - the prairie oyster
with a beer a little hair of the dog a
highly caloric beer I think that's your
a hangover cure
why don't we invent the hard-boiled
prairie oyster hard yeah but we listen
we gotta come up with a name the Prairie
Rock Prairie Rock I'm dr. Keller wertham
I'm Fran Kranz thanks for visiting the
GQ hangover lab for more tips and
hangover cures subscribe to the channel